ursprünglich hatte das spektakuläre
maßnahmen projekt mal das ziel schon im
jahr 2022 menschen auf dem mars siedeln
zu lassen jeder konnte sich bewerben und
es gab einen riesigen medienhype das
krasse laut plan werden die astronautin
astronauten nie wieder zur erde
zurückkehren sondern ihr ganzes leben
auf dem mars verbringen doch der
zeitplan wurde immer weiter nach hinten
geschoben und lange war es ruhig um mord
an
doch wie ist eigentlich der aktuelle
stand der mission ihr habt euch dieses
thema auf whatsapp gewünscht wir
übrigens zu wort kommt dass der vater am
ende des videos bekommen jetzt alle
wichtigen facts zum thema herzlich
willkommen bei klicks um science-fiction
wir berichten ja immer wieder über die
pläne private raumfahrtunternehmen
menschen auf den mars zu schicken
denn das ganze ist einfach ein richtig
krasses dauerbrennerthema und super
spannend und es wird früher oder später
realität ihren mast beispielsweise mit
seiner firma spacex eine rakete namens
big felken rocket oder big fucking
rockend soll bereits 2024 menschen zum
mars schießen bis zu 200 menschen
gleichzeitig will er mit dieser rakete
zum mars schicken können außerdem gibt
es ja noch das maß direct projekt von
robert zu bringen hier sollen zunächst
mal nur vier leute auf dem mars
geschafft werden um dort stationen und
andere überlebensmöglichkeiten zu
installieren heute geht es hier um die
pläne des niederländischen unternehmens
baselland drop um die sind wirklich
großen mehrere tausend bewerbungen waren
zusammengekommen angeblich 2015 gab es
dann eine erste vorauswahl seitdem
stehen 100 bewerber auf der liste von
denen am ende tatsächlich 40 astronauten
aus verlauten für immer eine maß
kolonisation bilden sollen
die castings sind wohl nicht ohne
physische und psychische tests sind zu
absolvieren
zudem gibt es auch eine exakte kopie der
macht station in der sich die
kandidatinnen und kandidaten auf ihr
vielleicht zukünftiges leben vorbereiten
können
der nunmehr aktualisierte plan von
baslers drop sieht so aus im jahr 2031
sollen die ersten vier siedler zum mars
aufbrechen und ihr könnt es euch schon
denken dass one-way-ticket bedeutet
keinesfalls den start einer schönen
luxusreise mit fünf sternen denn erst
einmal auf dem mars angekommen werden
die siedler bestimmt keine langeweile
haben die to do liste ist lang zunächst
einmal sollen sich die astronauten um
ihr zuhause kümmern und die siedlung
bauen solarmodule müssen installiert
werden und gewächshäuser gebaut werden
das essen will geerntet und zubereitet
werden dazu heißt es auf der website von
mars wann unser ziel ist es den
teilnehmern zu ermöglichen einen raum
von zehn metern breite und 50 metern
länge zu bauen also eine großzügige
umgebung in der man leben kann und wo
man auch bäume anpflanzen kann das wird
den mars zu einem viel schöneren ort zum
leben machen
wenn diese basis erst einmal steht soll
dann vor allem geforscht werden
wie hat sich der mars wohl entwickelt
gibt es dort leben die astronautin
astronauten sollen selbst forschen aber
außerdem auch daten sammeln
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler auf der erde auswerten
können natürlich gibt es aber auch
zeiten zum entspannen lesen man sport
oder aber das internet nutzen um freunde
unserer mehr zuhause zu kontaktieren
oder aber filme anfordern
die dann über einen server auf den mars
hochgeladen werden bestimmte websites
werden tatsächlich ständig auf dem mars
mars web server aktualisiert andere
brauchen achtung bis zu 44 minuten
wenn die siedlung immer größer wird
müssen die astronauten und astronauten
sich auf eine art gesellschaftssystem
einigen wie sie die hierarchien und wie
können entscheidungsprozesse fair und
vernünftig ablaufen das alles klingt
jetzt erst mal ziemlich entspannt aber
man sagt selbst dass solch eine reise
keinesfalls risikolos ist es könnte
nicht nur probleme und unfälle bei start
und landungen geben sondern auch beim
eintritt in die marsatmosphäre dazu muss
man in einer offiziellen stellungnahme
massmann wird alle möglichen
vorkehrungen treffen um sicherzustellen
dass die mission so sicher wie möglich
ist wenn man unsere mission allerdings
mit der ersten mond mission 1969
vergleicht wird schnell klar dass diese
mission viel sicherer ist ja so soll die
rakete mehrmals unbemannt getestet
werden zudem sollen kapseln bereits vor
missions- staat den eintritt in die
atmosphäre simulieren doch warum genau
hat sich das projekt den mars und nicht
einen anderen planeten ausgesucht wir
haben ja hier schon öfter darüber
berichtet der mars ist aus verschiedenen
gründen tatsächlich ein planet auf dem
man sich leben theoretisch vorstellen
kann beispielsweise hat er zumindest
eine dünne atmosphäre die vor kosmischer
strahlung schützt zum anderen sind dort
die temperaturen hinnehmbar
und es gibt genug sonnenlicht das man
nutzen könnte zudem ist der tag nacht
rhythmus auf dem mars denen der erde
sehr ähnlich ein tag auf diesem planeten
dauert 24 stunden 39 minuten und 35
sekunden also fast so wie hier auf der
erde
natürlich können menschen nicht einfach
so ohne technische hilfsmittel hierhin
umziehen aber um es in worten von massow
anzusagen
im vergleich zur venus ist der mars ein
paradies vor kurzem hat der chef des
unternehmens in einem interview im
independent auch von anderen dauerhaften
siedlung außerhalb der erde gesprochen
demnach kann er sich auch missionen zu
den jupiter monde und der venus
vorstellen aber zurück zum mars laut dem
aktuellen fahrplan auf der maas website
steht die nächste etappe im jahr 2022 an
dann soll eine art demo mission zum mars
starten
mit dabei unter anderem eine kamera um
einen video streams zu installieren
zudem soll ein experiment zeigen das
wasser einfach aus dem mars boden
gewonnen werden kann und ein experiment
mit solarpanelen soll zeigen dass
ausreichend erneuerbare energie für die
siedlung bereitgestellt werden kann vier
jahre später also 2026 sieht der
fahrplan vor einen ersten rover zum mars
zu bringen soll dann den besten ort für
die siedlung herausfinden 2029 sollen
dann laut plan sechs fracht mission
starten unter anderem mit einem zweiten
rover zwei wohneinheiten und einer
versorgungseinheit nachdem dann 2030 die
außenposten die ankunft der ersten kurve
im detail vorbereitet haben soll die
erste kuh 2031 dann zum mars abheben und
2032 auf dem roten riesen eintreffen die
besatzung wird sicherlich bis zu 48
stunden brauchen um sich an die
schwerkraft zu gewöhnen
schließlich waren sie die letzten sechs
bis acht monate im weltraum unterwegs
das alles steht aber noch in den sternen
denn wie bereits gesagt wurden die
deadlines bereits mehrfach weit nach
hinten geschoben finanziert werden soll
das ganze jahr übrigens auch durch die
rechte an einer fernsehsendung die dann
das leben der leute auf die erde
überträgt big brother auf dem mars also
der deal mit einer holländischen
fernsehfirma der ist allerdings geplatzt
jetzt hofft man auf sponsoren ja viele
kritiker sind schon lange davon
überzeugen dass das projekt lieber in
hollywood stattfinden sollte unseren
heutigen technologien seien noch lange
nicht so weit so das argument vieler
weltraum expertinnen und experten und
der plan ist tatsächlich nur bereits
vorhandene technik einzusetzen um sich
kostspielige neuentwicklungen zu sparen
und ja wir haben zwar schon einige
roboter zum mars gebracht oder eben auch
den astra corsa city im jahr 2002
aber ein roboter ist noch lange keine
kuh aus astronauten astronauten
bemannten flügen gelten so recht viel
strengeren sicherheitsanforderungen
sowohl der staat die mehrmonatige reise
als auch die landung müssen sicher
abzuwickeln sein das alles braucht vor
allem starke nerven und auch die
psychologie könnte hier eine
entscheidende rolle spielen das zeigen
isolationsexperiment wie soll die crew
zusammenhalten wenn sie ausschließlich
aus leuten besteht die egal um welchen
preis einfach ruhm und ehre kassieren
wollen als erste menschen auf dem mars
in die geschichte eingehen wollen und
dabei den tod immer im nacken sitzen
haben
weltraumexperten wie ein forschungsteam
vom renommierten massachusetts institute
of technology mit sehen vor allem die
dünne atmosphäre und die
sauerstoffkonzentration als ein deutlich
einschränken faktor dazu sagt oliver de
weck forscher vom mtb sagen nicht
schwarz und weiß was wann ist
undurchführbar aber unter den
ausgangsvoraussetzungen die sehr zeit
gegeben sind ist das alles nicht
realistisch dazu kommen noch viele
weitere medizinische und technische
probleme und so gibt es schätzung dass
die chance nach drei monaten auf dem
mars noch zu leben bei weniger achtung
als 20 prozent liegen ja wenn ihr als
erstes neues zum thema mars besiedlungen
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
dann meldet euch hier bei potsdam
dann erfährt er von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion
von clic somit machen und mehr themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und damit entscheiden was
hier auf dem kanal passiert ja einfach
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der genau vergessen hier
geht es weiter und dafür auch
draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars da
hat ihnen masken seinen finger ins spiel
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran